how about a careful boy's car how about
just a careful boy's how about we just
start selling black
belts but I can't wear one you guys get
all have one I can't have one you know
what barbell did that was tight uh you
guys did the Crocs um what are they
called jibbit you guys have JB
[Laughter]
[Music]
jibbit welcome back to careful boys
where we are afraid of everything here
everyone available now the linkow
everyone
see everybody T up up and on top of now
we got more
careful okay so this is a this a good
video for this actually because today
we're talking about how JK merch is
crushing it hey hey hey thank you guys
thank you guys so much seriously thank
you but also as Ryan gets his up there
we go what is some dope JK merch that we
can use to BU our audience to make
profit
the way you say that well it's
disgusting whenever you want profit it's
bad yeah evil capitalist that's what I
said you dirty landlords can we get it
is this good
content and it's Nick's face yeah and my
face like this some of the fans have
like the best ideas but I'm just like
what are some of them um one of them is
Anthony dancing and saying did it didn't
happen nor I mean what he what's he
referring to yeah which fan said that
what's the context of I got to give you
a shout bro let me give you the fact
that yeah but I don't really know quite
about enough about it yet a fan
submitted idea what's the idea he
actually I copied I [__]
screenshotted this [__] and circled it
for the world to see right here I'll
give you guys the uh the
picture bunny walking said Uncle chin
shirt is fire but also need a Steve
shirt saying Anthony Lee had a dance
about how 911 11's not
real that's a good one Steve saying it
on the Shir you think Steve should be
like this anony and then Anthony's like
in the back dancing like this and it's
not real didn't happen yeah that's
really good shoulder proof show me show
me proof is my favorite show the proof
is really good or we have Anthony and
Bin Laden back to back in a b boy stance
with sunglasses on or like shake hands
like
this oh and the run like Run DMC with
like the gold ropes in the buck house
the squad
beened that be tight oh
dude can we just have a Al-Qaeda
line the [__] Anthony being a alaa rider
you guys do realize that there's a
little bit of a contradiction because
that means it did
happen tell the wory about the details
dude make it so real yeah when you you
can't explain art yeah just adding too
much words you don't want the collab the
collab is going to be the hottest I'm
going to focus on real merch we're going
to make so know next how about those
tube socks that everybody want quick hey
let's deflect if we did that's not
deflecting let's bring it back to actual
tube socks and you know it's going to be
like this High we can call it a crew cuz
realistically nobody's going to buy tube
socks no's going to buy tube socks right
what about another shirt what about
another shirt it's like Hurricane
Katrina and then you have Anthony going
like I don't even see
it he goes what hurricane just different
disasters
water it's just a little water why is
everyone so mad all right how about just
all the [__] fallen and and quitting
members of JK that's [__] up why got
breath there dude it's pretty good I
like that I like the Fallen members CL
it could be their Silhouettes with
question marks too where did they go too
far man to where did they go too far
yeah oh and then it should have the
current only over 2,000 Souls were lost
on 911 never forget it should have me it
should also have me Nick Anthony and
Ryan and it's like we're on
Deck you guys are on the bench we're The
Chopping Block we're ready to be who's
next question mark yeah who's next or
just pictures with like our eyes I'm for
sure first in line damn yeah you might
get a couple boats we do need some Nick
Bas merch though okay I got one for Nick
check it out I got one for Nick there's
a you remember that that one thing where
you saw all the white presents and then
you saw one black one and they were just
kind of like it wasn't like super
detailed but you knew that that's stood
for the 44th or what [__] all of us all
was just a bunch of
ears and then there's just one that's
really good yeah that's really good I
don't think I don't like that that's
good that's good Nick if you like it
you're leaning into the joke you're
owning it yeah that's good I don't want
to I don't want to have any ear based
stuff no ear based stuff you're called
Nick the ear that's lit that was my
choice that wasn't my choice who made
your Instagram who choice is that what
if we sold what if we sold a [__] up
Ear Pod that's in a weird shape it only
fits your ear that'd be kind of that
that sounds like a a lot of what if it's
a necklace kind of like a dog tack but
it's just one ear you know how look
gangster War people are like I collect
ears that's kind of cool I like JK News
why would you do that the Cockroaches of
YouTube can't can't be killed can't be
we just keep surviving yeah true oh
that's why it's a cockroach oh oh I was
thinking about how we're insect
like can't be sto it might need to not
be so like
blatant though might need to be like a
cockroach wearing like a JK logo
necklace and just like in the corner or
something you know like still alive how
about just a shot of Nick going like
this and it just says do you have a
picture of the
guy what does he look like no Nick doing
this yeah yeah yeah yeah do you have a
picture of the guy can I see what he
looks like having done zero work all day
while we were up slaving over this
[__] kick it back with sunglasses on
even too he's like look at it partially
after he came late training a
client dude I want I want to I want
people to be able to go to like you're
you ever you ever park at like a hot
place like in Nevada or like you're in a
hot parking lot in La whatever you put
up a a Nick Sun deflector in your
windshield deflector you're deflecting
all thatu yeah that's Nick deflector and
the deflectors got ears oh that's good
it's like this and then on the bottom
it's is this good content is this good
content should I give up that's should I
shut the [__] up one of Nick's famous
monologues from like these 25 30 minute
videos where he said nothing for 12
minutes we write all of it out just as
long as the [__] it's just a whole
transcript a whole transcript on the
entire Sun deflector and you're like I
still don't know what he's talking about
people can see for themselves he said
nothing for 20 minutes yeah for 20
minutes and at the end is this good
content It's hard talking on camera
okay that has to happened in a while in
in the original writing a shirt that
just says Mar great
Mar you have a picture of that too we
have a picture of that that's even
better that's
nice would you ever get that tatted on
you um you might get a string of tattoos
now I want to get yeah I should I might
as well right if I got this [__]
thing I might
get I don't know probably to cover up
this tattoo that's good we could think
basic we just get it was like a visu
jeans back in the day we just get a pair
of pants and then it's just got both
tats right here and then on the back
pocket it says
Bart yo or B why on the back pocket why
does it say my name yeah it's like a
small little like you know from the
Creator oh like he signed it yeah it
would be dope to get sweats with the
double in the front yeah be kind of
tight who would want
that ironically a lot we could really if
it's sweats too sweats with the bro I
think we can get that maybe that's a
good idea let's do it it's a good idea
but I'm just wondering do you guys
actually want put in the
comments I'll say this I'll say this
socks or sweats hey sweats with just one
guaranteed oh sweat with just
one cuz I'll I'll wear it one the other
one is just short like that hey that's a
sick ass reveal to pull your sweats up
and the tattoos there y black sweats
with just a white version of this is
that what you guys want to put in the
comments below I would honestly
in the back pocket opposite side cuz you
need opposite balance that's where has
the JK logo i' wear that too or careful
boys care Boo the JK logo careful boys
yeah [__] the
JK well honestly no just as a cast
member for many years that logo compared
to careful boy [__] it's just not nearly
as lit careful boy shit's so lit I agree
careful boys is the name of the crew
just kidding news is the channel it's
the channel there it is there it is it's
a new era dude we are careful boys first
creating content on the just kidding
News Channel that's right that's right
what other iconic JK think cleen's
butthole and then three mil question
mark three mil three mil question
question mark that's really good well
she said she was going to get it on her
butthole but then she didn't get the
tattoo on her butthole damn I you said
she said a she was going to get fear
everyone on her butthole said
it just every time we say Colleen's name
we just have to say it a little bit
differently colen Ken all the spellings
Kos I think these are pretty great ideas
what about Ryan we got some Ryan Bas
merch how about we just like make a
beard it's just and you could you could
wear it novelty beard you could wear
Ryan
beards this has been the best ERA of JK
merch though like before we'd always
just get funny stupid ideas like we used
to have one that said underwear model
and it was just a print of an like a
like a brief I think you guys just have
real artist on the show I actually liked
brand name shirt that was my favorite
one you guys did yeah name brand shirt
name brand shirt I like that one a
lot that was a good shirt what about the
[__] pesos and I think we actually have
some over there well that's part of the
problem though is that it was like such
an old reference that but then people
would go to our new videos and then like
that merch is still there but now it's
like feels cooler cuz everyone's more
current there was one that was like pole
vaulting isn't a sport I saw that and
then it was funny but only for that
yeah yeah there was like 10 shirts that
sold yeah yeah if we can get custom
fanny packs oh dude fanny packs would be
cuz you wasar fny pack and maybe like
print like a stove on it all right
that's not funny dude that's not funny
that's
funny did to take the the knob from the
stove and attach it on
yeah I don't know why it just turned on
it just turned on how about a ghee a
Nick ghee n that's too much that be
insane dude that would be so cool you
guys would lose money on that I think we
would definitely lose how about a
careful boy's car how
about a careful boy how about we just
start selling black
belts but I can't wear one you guys get
to all have one I can't have one [__] no
we sell black belts when people order
them it right Brown oh
what you know what barbell did that was
tight uh you guys did the Crocs um what
are they called jibbit you guys have
jbit
jbits what's a jbits frean morning dude
Tiff was like I was like I got some jiz
bits I was like what the [__] is it yeah
what's a jiz bit wait Tiff really said
that some bits right here yeah yeah and
I was like what the [__] is she's like
jbits for Crocs I was like what the [__]
is a jbit but she she meant jibbit or
whatever you put it on these one of
these bro if we get some JK Crocs bro Oh
you mean like a uh oh like those pins at
that level that would be more of a
careful boys Crocs collabo yeah but
that's probably not going to happen
because Crocs is smart so yeah yeah but
we can make jibbit but Crocs
collaborated with idiocracy we're
idiocracy dude like no we're just idiots
we're contributing to it for sure but
they that's how they got
big I'm just trying to reach where we
can reach yeah that's all this
is here we're not going to have an
official collaboration yeah we're sick
at t-shirts okay we want cars we want
Auto hey Nick right though the merch
that we're not would look DB on a
trucker hat yeah like or a dad hat that
one yeah the care the careful beer logo
would look great on a trucker hat you
know we also be tight this is not even
merch but if we painted a billboard like
the sky so a plane crashes into it cuz
they couldn't tell that something was
there that's a low ass plane that's a
great
idea paint it clouds and wait for the
moment that a plane crashes and then
record that video and then we'll do JK
news and at the end we'll be like
news low key though we do got to take a
page out of Nightcrawler [__]
baby book and like we should like some
ghetto ass area we should put up a
careful boys billboard Kazumi's book is
pretty expensive though really her [__]
she only does expensive [__] I mean her
stunts are they take a bunch we could
she she could sponsor us no no no we
could definitely get a a billboard like
in okoklahoma
I swear to God we Oklahoma yeah we keep
dunking on that state you could but yo
imagine we just got careful boys
billboard up in some cheap place and we
just asked one fan to go take a photo
there's yeah there's got to be there's
got to be at least one and then from
there we make a shirt out of that photo
I'm down yeah there's got to be one
where it's like it's like 100 bucks a
month or something dude Pac for of some
[__] yeah I'm down I mean if you're just
getting it for a short time we're
recycling the t-shir t-shirt profits
into further promo and marketing for
more t-shirt profits you know you know
what you can do you buy the in between
time of billboards so you're renting
from another you're subing the billboard
then you can get it for just a week you
don't have to get the whole month how do
you get a billboard that's like in
Hollywood in someone's backyard you know
how sometimes you look and it's like
yeah it's like someone's rooftop or some
[__] how do we take how do we take like
what is the equivalent of like you know
how like in Canada they like they shove
this device into a [__] tree and like
maple syrup starts to come out yeah when
you say device it's just another piece
of wood or something is it it's like a
metal thing right how do we just shove
that into a fan and have their money
drip out into a [__]
wallet we make a shirt that that
details one one by one buy the plane
sell the
drugs that's actually really good okay
that's our second good idea Joe's
laundering money it's our second good
idea and for the rest of a merch we ever
make we put on a venmo QR code on the
back where people can donate more so
it's a Perpetual advertisement that's
how you do it what's that QR code oh
donate to JK news constant that's a
great idea guys right and then like
that's semi Lan but okay cool yeah
Beggars bunch of Beggars I feel like the
fans are going to have something way
better and then there's going to be a
ton of likes on it and then it's just
going to blow all of our minds and we're
going to be like that's what we need to
me and then we do it no we're going to
do it that's our track record for sure
and then we block that fan yeah yeah we
block them and we we take all the money
for
ourselves oh I like that idea we steal
their idea oh I like that and then we
make profits oo there's nothing more
evil o making profits what about a stick
figure of can just like dumping like
media into a trash
can it's just it says can and delete and
delete and delete like those one shirts
yeah with Thea yeah deleting footage
delet since
2004 that would be tight if we could
sell a SD card that says can on it and
when you put it into your computer just
gives you a virus right away Del all
your [__] yeah I hope he edits this
video you probably won't these are great
ideas yeah these are really good yeah
what if we hit up Sonora town and ask
them if they're down for a t-shirt
collab they have shirts we should do a
collab with montere Park the city of
monter Park dude that'd be pretty cool
let's hey let's start hitting people up
and see if they wanted to teach or
collab what would be the collab dude we
should Bobby hun up and get ignored by
him
yeah not that's not a bad idea hey
sliding those DMs like I know you know
how on Sunday at Family Food Fest that's
when we'll start start Ping doing some
connections pleas how would we collab
with with the city ask the city you
didn't you didn't hear him no but what's
the idea what's the collaboration hear
him it's just a it's a collab yeah it
just says the city of monre Park so like
we do a video right and then the city of
monre Park does a video and then we we
we shoot shout out each other at the end
City yeah we just shout we shout each
other out at the end of the video this
guy this guy's been on YouTube for how
long you lived here for how long we need
to have the city city hall and then we
need to have like a garden like a
regular and then you have us someone
draws Us in doing JK news on a table
outside the city hall oh hey you know be
cool yeah you get a mural made on a
random wall yeah they should make a
statue there's a map of the city and
then there's a pin that designates all
the places that we illegally shot
yeah hey we'll get we'll get um Ethan
Klein from H3 watching our video and
it's a it's a t-shirt of him being like
what is this [__]
format is that what and his producer and
his producer like no jaky news they're
dope yeah they're dope and then
Anthony's like what is is this [__]
format what the [__] are they doing why
are they dressed like why they Dr how do
they even do this with these tables what
the [__] are they doing dude I know our
next [__] corporate collab check it
out careful boys X Ethan
Allen and it's Bart hiding in a closet
at Ethan Allen that's good Ethan Allen's
like hey dude your dad's not getting in
here protecting boys from child abuse
that's good dude all right next time I'm
going to go on one cuz I know there's
one in downtown serlin and I'll go climb
into a cabinet and I'll have Gio take a
picture of
me love it that's a funny ass collab
Ethan all and like everything in JK like
when we filmed in Trump Tower and nobody
could tell we were in Trump Tower nobody
will know he's in Ethan when he posts a
video of him in a dark place it's just
going to be a photo of a cabinet closed
but we'll know because we know how how
dumb we all are that he's actually in an
Ethan Allen but it won't matter I could
have just filmed him in a U-Haul box bro
I've been trying to find a wa was was it
a grandfather clock or a hutch what was
it the thing you hid in it was one of
yeah you did like one of those like
cupboard like you know like those '90s
where like you're supposed to display
all your [__] bows and [__] one of
those things I could have so I've been
trying to find cabin dude I've been
trying to find one for the office just
so can you know [__] with your memories
you can get like any one of those are so
cheap just normally but Ethan all one
specifically costs so much more
but I'm Holding Out for a good deal cuz
his name brand bro I want to get one for
here as a monument oh you've been
looking out for an actual Ethan Allen
one on I was looking for grandfather
clocks cuz I thought that's what you hit
in but if it's a hutch then that's why
did I think that too I thought that too
I thought Grandfather maybe I forgot I
mean I was so scared I don't remember he
only remembers the inside he doesn't
remember the outside let's just say it's
a grandfather CL cuz that's cooler I
mean I was so [__] scared I don't
know
dude what if it was just a dresser that
makes more sense could have been could
have been a dress
he said grandfather clock I'm pretty
sure yeah maybe it was a grandfather
clock I don't know we need we need
accuracy for the emotional attachment
okay so we got to do our due diligence
we got to watch the original video so
that when Bart walks into this office
he's triggered emotionally when he when
we're about to film but I have an alert
for that so anytime one goes up for sale
I I see the notification and it's always
so much more expensive I'm like come on
man they look just the same to get a $40
one but you know what some of these
videos they're so much older and like
it's one of those you had to be there so
we have to always like re-upload that
segment with the shirt that we promote
I'll tell you what'll hit right now
daycore of being in Ryan's cult oh that
dude in the comment section every video
going I'm a little impressed he's he's
cool who yeah and I'm about to be hella
impressed in like 100 more
days dude he'll give up that and
I oh yeah that guy's consistent too yeah
but why come here and say that it
doesn't matter unless we can buy t-shirt
or the or the Nick is so funny he's
great too Nick is the funniest I like
how you're just talking about your own
joke yeah I don't like that joke I
didn't it's not a joke I don't like that
joke oh my God it's not is it a
joke I don't think they're kidding I
think it's a bit I don't like it and the
video right now turn it off okay okay
guy who's in more podcast than any of us
hey [__] you dude that's a dis that's a
[__] discs [__] you that takes us
back to is this good content is his good
content is a good one that gets said a
lot but Nick is the biggest influencer
here yeah that's not true he's the
coolest cuz he's anti-
influencer